what's wrong with being a nice guy
that's that's a good question you know
when I put out a book called No More Mr
Nice Guy I'm sure a lot of people picked
it up it wait a minute there's already
enough not nice guys out there why
somebody write a book teaching men how
to be not nice the the problem with
being a nice guy just a quick elevator
pitch is is that a nice guy is a guy who
inaccurately internalize the belief
system a very young age I'm not okay
just as I am so he's trying to do two
things very unconsciously usually one is
become what he thinks everybody else
wants him to be so he'll be liked and
loved and get his needs met and get laid
hopefully uh regularly and hide anything
about himself that might get a negative
reaction from people uh hiding his needs
his wants his sexuality so while he's
trying to get laid he's hiding his
sexuality um so a core problem with nice
guy syndrome is nice guys tend to be un
uh
unauthentic uh there there there's not
not a real them there they're trying to
become something hide something and uh
that tends to make them fairly dishonest
untrustworthy frustrated resentful
passive
aggressive a whole list of traits that
can go along and and mainly it prevents
and I'm a recovering nice guy so I'm not
speaking down to anybody you know it
keeps us from just being ourselves
living up to our our full potential
having what we want in life having a
good time and so just a lot of baggage
comes along with it what are the
component parts of being a nice guy what
are the traits that they embody or
project where you what you'll recognize
most often and what listeners May
recognize in themselves core tendency is
often people pleasing seeking external
validation and and for men usually that
seeking validation from women even even
gay guys I find tend to do it uh even if
they don't plan on having sex with the
women they we we can talk more about
this but we're we've learned from birth
to please women so there's that people
pleasing that external
validation um failing to live up to
one's full potential a basic core
dishonesty you know thinking you know
I'm I'm a good guy I'm pretty honest I
always laugh when men tell me they're
pretty honest I say that's actually a
contradiction of terms um you're honest
or you're not
um and
um and just you know for most nice guys
there's just a certain dull depression
that they live with just thinking you
know I should be happy I should be
getting what I want I should be getting
love I I should I should but I'm not and
I don't know why not and so there's
there's a lot of characteristics but the
core piece you'll see the most often is
that people pleasing that seeking of
external
validation who is the prototypical night
guy Avatar like describe him for
me oh he's you
know he's just just that guy that's you
know walking through life trying to make
everybody happy trying not to do
anything wrong don't want to [__]
anything up doesn't want to piss anybody
off uh goes along to get along you know
we've heard that you know happy wife
happy life if I just make everybody
happy everything's good uh I I have a
course that I've taught for a number of
years called nice guys don't finish last
they R him midle management so he's good
at being good but you know he doesn't
Excel he doesn't stand out because
standing out is actually really scary
for nice guys uh it's too much attention
it's too much
expectation um so you know when I
started working with nice guys 30 years
ago um most of the men I worked with you
know probably were around my age I was
in my early 30s at that time and um so
it was a lot of baby uh Baby Boom
generation guys you know they they were
trying to be different than their
fathers the World War II you know man uh
they were in that protest generation
against Vietnam growing their hair out
getting in touch with their feminine
side and and so a lot of the men I
worked with you know kind of grew up in
that era but I've been doing this for a
while and so you know my son's 38 for
example so you know I I work with
Millennials Millennials men younger than
that and what's funny is whereas my
generation lot of them men uh kind of
attribute part of their nice guys stuff
to well my dad wasn't there or you know
my parents divorced or you know he
worked all the time or he was an
alcoholic nowadays I hear a lot of men
say oh my dad was a nice guy and and
about all he taught me about life was
don't piss off your mother and and
because he was walking around eggshells
trying not to piss off my mother so you
know I I've seen that whole range all
the way from the guys that were reacting
to you know the the the [__]
um patriarchal father to now the guys
that were raised by nice guys and they
don't know any other way of being it's
like one generation had the Tyrant and
the other generation had the compliant
that's a good way to put it that's nice
yeah the Tyrant to compliant yeah it was
um but here's the interesting thing
right is it's so fascinating that you
had one generation that was rebelling in
their neness even if that niess isn't
that nice yeah and then another
generation that was following in their
Ness so there seems to be a particular
stickiness to niess if tyrants that are
emotionally unavailable and not nice are
able to create nice guys and
nice fathers are also we're in big
trouble we're so what's why is it so
prevalent what is what is this pull are
we as men are we inculcating ating or
absorbing something from the world is
this the way that we were raised by Mom
and Dad is the what's the Gen what's the
origin what's the Genesis the seed of
this well that's a good question of
course and of of course what every nice
guy wants how did I get to be this way
you know who cursed me with this yeah
yeah I I quickly learned when I started
working with nice guys again 30 years
ago that there is no one you know one
size fit all how you how you got to be a
nice guy I I thought there was it for I
thought they were all like me you know
uh disconnected from their father in
some significant way uh you know
significantly raised by their mother
trying to please their mom and and uh
and I thought well that that explains it
all but it didn't and
um there's so many pieces to go into a
lot of men I work with that identify as
being nice guys I think part of is their
temperament part of is just they're
easygoing you know my my my mother would
often say in adulthood to women I was
dating oh Bobby never did like conflict
and I'm I'm thinking well thanks Mom you
know what are you telling these women be
nice to my son don't be mean to him but
I'm also thinking who does like conflict
you know I I do tend to marry women who
like to fight but I for me it's kind of
like you know can't can't can't you know
instead of us you you doing something
that starts a fight I say to them can't
I just yell at you a little bit you cry
and then I hold you is't that really
what you know this is all about anyway
and my wife will always say no it
doesn't countless you're really mad at
me um so I I don't like conflict in
particular so that's my temperament so
disposition that many of the nice guys
will have the raw materials of someone
that's a
little verse Y part of my nature but but
that's just kind of one category of nice
guy the other one that that I bumped
into I call often those I'm so good nice
guy he's the guy that just always did
everything right no matter what you know
but the other side I talk about in No
More Mr Nice Guy is what I call I'm so
bad nice guy this is the one that you
know maybe started rebelling at an early
age maybe had ADHD undiagnosed you know
he's always impulsive getting in trouble
you know not following through getting
yelled at getting punished starts doing
drugs and alcohol at 14 you know drops
out of school and then maybe at some
point has a come to Jesus moment
religion military gets married as a kid
death in the family he goes I got I I
got to quit you know self-destructing I
I gotta I got to be nicer so there's
that kind of nice guy as well so it's a
different temperament than than the than
the
other one of the pieces you know there's
so many pieces that go into this but to
answer your question how do we what's
the stickiness
part again I think a real core piece
that I see with so many nice guys is
this attempt to to please women
and I I was talking to somebody the
other day it it makes perfect sense
because if you think about it we're all
born to a woman our earliest caregiver
if it's not Mom it's probably some other
woman so from the time we're born our
very survival our sustenance our
okayness depends on a woman and probably
us getting along with that woman that's
probably a good thing right and so
that's really normal that the our first
experiences are how to how to negotiate
a relationship with a woman to make that
big powerful holds our our life in her
hands uh person how to make sure that's
okay and I don't know about in the UK
but when I was growing up uh in Seattle
I had one male teacher before I got to
Junior High does four times more female
fighter pilots in the US Air Force by
percentage than there are male
kindergarten teaches there you go you've
done your research so so I had one
teacher so that means just to learn how
to get from second to third grade not
only had to learn my Reading Writing and
arithmetic but how to please a woman
okay all of that's fine there's the
there's nothing inherently wrong with
that I think that's actually probably
the way it's always been but
historically I mean if we go back even
two or three generations but if you go
through most of human history at about
age 12 the man came into the boy's life
took him you know from the women took
him out had a masculine initiation
taught him how to get comfortable being
uncomfortable how to face his fear how
to live in the scary world of the
masculine and therefore and spent most
of his time from them on out with with
men in the masculine and and so he got
he moved through that what do I have to
do to please a woman so I think that's a
really normal thing that to to try to
please women survival for for every
young boy but what's what's missing is
there's no initiation to teach them how
to how to go face their fears in the
scary world of the masculine and quit
seeking the approval and validation of
women because there's this really
interesting Paradox that I I took me
years to find out and you know a lot of
men I work with takes you know it's it's
a big surprise is
oh pursuing women and trying to please
them doesn't make them interested in you
it doesn't make them like you it doesn't
make them want to have sex with you no
it actually doesn't actually not trying
to please women tends to make a guy more
interesting to women in general that's a
big Paradox to a lot of the men I work
with and it was for me you mean mean all
this me listening them talk about their
problems me trying to be different than
the jerks they complain about me
repressing my sexuality so it's not like
I just want that one thing from them you
know all that doesn't make them
interested in me no it doesn't actually
but they do seem to be drawn and
attracted to the guy who's comfortable
in his own skin living a life you know
on his terms connected with men uh put
in a big dent in the universe that is
really attractive but there's no no how
do I get This Woman's approval involved
in that whole mix what are the covert
contracts
oh I'm glad you asked that that's um
that's my favorite part I'm No More Mr
Nice Guy and I know uh many men read it
say Robert that is the biggest takeaway
the covert contracts are unspoken often
unconscious agreements that the nice guy
has with everything that's not him with
the world with god with women you know
which just how things work and in the
book I I I I'm a little bit General but
I'm broken it down to three specific
covert contracts that nice guys have
they're all if then uh if I do this then
this will happen they they all uh are
basically manipulative they all have
strings attached and often the nice guy
isn't aware of them and nobody else is
either so covert contract number one if
I'm a good guy I will be liked and loved
and get my and and going back to and the
women I'm trying to impress will want to
be with me and have sex with me so if
I'm good I'll be liked and love number
two if I meet everybody else needs
without them having to ask then they
will meet my needs without me having to
ask now unfortunately nobody else knows
this contract exists so they don't know
they're supposed to be reading our minds
and figure out what we want like we're
trying to do for them another core
problem with this is that nice guys are
actually really terrible receivers we're
not good at letting people do for us
we're not good at giving to ourselves so
that's covert contract number two covert
contract number three is if I do
everything right then I will have a
smooth Problem free world so it's kind
of a Peter panish kind of thing you know
I I I do everything right I'm I'm a good
guy but unfortunately we're we're we're
the player the referee the scorekeeper
we got the big scoreboard hey I've done
everything right how come this stuff
still isn't going the way it's supposed
to go in my life so nice guys are
walking around these Cobra contracts and
and you ask you know what are well what
what what's the core characteristic of a
nice guy one of them is is that they're
often really resentful you know they
might say well I'm kind of bugged or I'm
kind of frustrated but they're really
resentful and often rageful because I've
been doing this I've been doing it right
I've been following the rules I've been
you know being the good guy I've been
meeting your needs I've been you know
following all the rules you know how
come I'm when's it my turn how come I'm
not getting all the all the stuff that I
thought I would and that leads to a lot
of resentments and then that's one way I
can tell I tell nice guys they well how
do I know if I'm if I'm using contracts
and I go you'll know because you're
walking around resentful and pissed off
either because you didn't get back in
turn or you didn't get appreciated for
for all that that you did I I heard
somebody share a quote the other day
that I really like to me is another
really nice way of putting covert
contracts and this I guess was from Neil
Strauss and he says un um unspoken
expect expectations are premeditated
resentment isn't that that that is what
happens phal contract phenomenal by him
yeah
that so the frustration and the
resentfulness that's coming from
offering to the world something that you
think should be universally liked you
have there is there's no way that
anybody could be offended by what I'm
doing I'm following the rules I'm
offering the world lot whilst asking for
nothing in return yeah and the fact that
not asking for something in return
results in you getting nothing in return
funny how that works I I don't know but
it's I suppose this as well plays into
the dishonesty bit and it's so I
understand I would say that I'm I'm very
much in Nice Guy category um very much a
people pleaser uh my temperament is to
be averse to conflict as well um I've
made a dent in many ways but it's been
done
it's been done by weaving my way through
avoiding much of the the conflict uh
that that I would maybe need to um so I
suppose I can be at least in some
regards a uh a paragon or or like a a a
role model for the successful nice guy
in in many ways and and me too you know
again I don't like conflict but you know
I you know I'm doing okay there's
something I always felt I always felt
the fact that I wasn't
like my my go-to isn't
typically uh aggression that's not what
I lean into um despite the fact I've got
a background of fighting and and doing
other things and physical training and
stuff like that I always felt like it
emasculated me the fact that there was
something more heroic about being
someone that was quick to anger you know
there was something kind of typically
masculine about that and I think I
was not strong enough to say ashamed but
it felt it it didn't feel
as Grand to be someone who would be I
know that there's an ability in you know
being under control having your emotions
under control um but there's also a
degree of fragility I think that you can
sometimes feel with that also well let
me give one way to maybe look at the
model and and see if it fits what you're
saying is that when I was writing No
More Mr Nice Guy I really focused a lot
on shame being a core Foundation of nice
Sky syndrome that internalized belief
I'm not okay and inaccurately
internalized belief from our earliest
life experience few weeks old few few
months old by the time I finished
writing the book and it was you know
getting ready to be published by that
time I'd really come to also see that
anxiety plays maybe an equally
significant role uh in nice gu syndrome
so where everything that nice guys are
doing is trying to manage that sense of
Shame I'm not not okay I'm unlovable I'm
defective and their anxiety States you
know I might piss somebody off I might
get rejected I might get hurt I might
lose I might live foolish so you know
both of those States really play into it
and one of the things I've come to see
is is that whether we've got just to
kind of break it down whether we got
kind of the [__] jerk over here that
fighter that quick to fight guy or the
wussy dorat you know the nice guy over
here that's the avoidant and and kind of
doesn't like the conflict I think
they're they're both on the the same
Continuum I think they are both in a
fight flight freeze mode of managing
their interstates of anxiety the nice
guy is in the flight freeze bwn
sometimes added to that list and what
we'd call The Jerk is in the fight mode
now they're both still just trying to
manipulate people and situations outside
of them because they're anxious the nice
guy does it by being nice and avoidant
and not upsetting anybody and you know
waiting for it to blow over you all that
kind of where is you know the guy the
other end of the spectrum is is just he
just quick to react with aggression to
manage the people and situations around
him so so he doesn't feel afraid and
anxious and so men will often you know
they'll read my book or you know they'll
hear some of my information and they'll
say Robert I get that being a nice guy
isn't working and I don't want to be
that but I don't want to be the [__]
either you know where where's that
middle ground and I go I actually don't
know where the Tipping Point is between
two dysfunctional extremes it doesn't
exist right what what we're actually
talking about is is going to a different
plane a different level where we
actually learn to soothe ourselves where
we actually learn to be assertive where
we actually learn to have boundaries
where we actually learn to be
differentiated and ask ourselves what do
I want and follow through on it where
there's you know there's a whole
different plane of behavior versus just
what do I do to not feel anxious here
but again the nice guy and the jerk
probably neither one is aware that
they're trying to manage their anxiety
States and and it isn't until you
actually get told that maybe that's what
you're doing you go oh wow I never
thought about that before and then then
you actually can feel your anxiety
rather than trying to just manage it to
where it doesn't you know make you feel
so anxious is it a desire to feel safe
then to feel reassured yeah I I think
you know safety is at the core because
when I took Child Development 101 back
in grad school I think the very first
thing they told us one of the few things
maybe I remembered was that for every
child abandonment equals death so
children come into the world inherently
vulnerable right there's no one to take
care of us it takes humans longer to
mature and self-sufficiency than any
other animal on the planet you know our
grandfathers maybe that was about 12 or
14 you know uh my age was more you know
considered 18 21 22 now it's like 35 for
a young man to you know mature to be
able to take care of himself that's a
joke um but but it's true so we're
dependent completely dependent and if
somebody doesn't take care of us we die
so if we get abandoned neglected uh we
die so I know for me like when my wife
you know I'm uh my wife Lupita and I
have been married for seven years now
Mexican woman I met here in Mexico and
um she gets a look on her face and like
I I'll go into you know this mod of I
got I got to fix it she's upset she's
angry I got to make it better and you
know I've been working on this stuff for
30 years so you know not like I don't
know you know what's happening and I'll
just watch myself have this anxiety
state that I got to I got to talk her
down through over get her back to good
you know make her happy again and I'm
thinking why am I worried about what
this short little Mexican woman why what
look she has on her face I love her of
course but why why is that triggering
such depth of anxiety and really as I
really sat with it and worked with it it
triggers a really old emotional state
that does feel like I'm going to die if
this doesn't get better right now
I'm going to die and I I don't actually
have that thought in my head but my
reaction to it feels that intense that's
the embodied sensation if you that's the
EMB body the nervous system my emotional
operating system yeah yeah yeah I wonder
stepping outside of relationships for a
second or relationships with anybody
including
friendships one of the patterns that
I've noticed especially amongst some of
my friends that are nice guys or
recovering nice guys is a desire to do
things right oh of course to like a task
in and of itself uh I would guess that
nice guys are probably more orderly than
the normal person sources will be
stacked in the in the right way you know
mustn't have a room because again you'd
think that you'd think that okay I got
to do it right I gotta get do orderly
but you know I've got my camera angled
where you can't see what's over on the
sides all right it's a mess it is is not
terrible but um it it is Messier on the
sides than it is behind me okay and so
again a lot of the nice guys I work
with they may have perfectionistic
expectations of themselves um and some
worked really hard to to to meet them
and then they're they're in a state of
anxiety all the time but others I know
they go you I haven't made my bed in
years you know I don't pick up after
myself I can't remember the last time I
I checked my bank account balance so you
think would be that but but
ironically um there's not and and here's
a piece that that it may sound odd on on
the surface of it but when I talk with
nice guys about their fears and their
anxieties I think one of the biggest
anxiety or fear state that that the
typical nice guy might have isn't so
much a fear of failure fear of
foolishness fear looking foolish fear of
loss fear of making a mistake is fear of
success because what happens if I do get
it right what happens if I Rise up to a
level of success and then you know
there's things that can happen all of a
sudden the bar gets raised the
expectations are higher I'm in a
brighter Spotlight I might get attacked
I'm more visible um there there's so
many I I'll lose control over my time
all of these built-in anxieties of what
happens if I'm too successful so again A
lot of times the nice guys will
unconsciously I don't really like the
word self-sabotage but they'll get in
their own way of living up to to their
full potential and keeping things messy
around you is actually a pretty good way
to you know you know not live up to your
full potential not check in your bank
account every now and then you know
that'll bite you on the app sooner or
later isn't it isn't it interesting that
the almost universality of high ability
of dishonest do you want to uh do you
need to sort the
dog this is a regular occurrence I can
see she's usually in the room with me
and and she's a deer she's my bring her
in she can chill yeah the problem is
she's upset because somebody's out front
and I'm the only one home and I don't
want to go deal with whoever might be
out there okay it could just be my wife
getting home with my daughter from
school could be so um yeah she's just
being a good girl let me know exactly
poy there's somebody out there there's
somebody out there let's go let's go and
it may have been she just saw cat so you
know I I I don't know so be it um she
walked away so hopefully she's bored of
you now yeah it's interesting that there
is uh this almost universality of uh not
having healthy boundaries yeah of being
dishonest of being manipulative although
you don't think that you are you're
you're overly pliable in a way that
means that you change yourself to get
the outcome that you want from people
but it seems at least based on what
you've said here that there there are
appears to be a boundary at least
typically among the nice guys where this
doesn't outside of relationships
friendships family dating Etc this
doesn't spread out into
a uh overbearing desire for for
orderliness and and sort of
perfectionism in all areas of life you
know with regards to an obsession about
getting it right about being everything
being I just what I'm to say is it's not
univ where the other where the other
stuff is yeah but it's what it shows or
at least what it says to me is that
there's something it's it's obvious that
ground zero for this stuff is
relationships you know that that would
have been my first thought as well
because it is for me and it is for many
nice guys but you know what I've I've
seen guys who are total Nice Guys in
relationship and they get on the job and
they kick ass you know that they're
highly successful at work I've known
other people that it showed up you know
uh at work where they troll nice guy and
going along to getting along and never
really stepping up or never launching
you know that that business and but at
home you know they their wife would say
he's not a nice guy he's nice to
everybody else but he's not nice to me
so it it can be interesting and and that
would again when I started working with
nice guys I just assume there's a one
piece fits all and and there's really
not now there are those certain
commonalities but I think partly because
we're also dealing with temperament that
for example maybe you and I had very
different life experiences maybe we have
some similarities of temperament some
differences different life experiences
we're not going to turn out just the
same we may still have those Tendencies
of you know seeking approval avoiding
conflict you know kind of a uh oh you
know I'm so good why doesn't everybody
like me and everybody try to be just
like me um
there might be some similarities but we
might be very different and still relate
to this as yes I'm a nice guy understood
what about hidden Behavior they keep
things hidden from themselves they keep
things hidden else why is that so common
why is it common because you know those
two things you know when we first
started you asked me you know what what
is the nice guy and basically and and I
said he's the guy trying to get
everybody's approval and validation you
know holding your finger up which ways a
wind blowing but the other piece is that
hiding things about ourselves you know
hiding anything for example that might
get that look on my wife's face you know
oh she got that look I must have done
something I better not do that again and
again that began at a very very early
age when getting that look from somebody
important to us might result in getting
slapped getting smacked getting
neglected getting yelled at getting
shaken whatever so nice guys is is part
of that I got to hide whatever there is
about me that tends to create these
negative reactions around me but often
there's another piece not again not
Universal but often for Nice Guys in
their family system somebody has been
defined as the needy person the most
important person could be Dad could be
mom could be a sibling and their needs
were more important there all the
attention and focus went on you know
making sure dad never got pissed off
making sure Mom didn't go on a tiate
making sure you know brother doesn't you
know whatever you know he's sick or he's
he's out of control so often for nice
guys we we try to become this needless
want never Rock the Boat never be a
moment's problem kind of person so what
we interpret is us having needs draws
too much attention and and you know my
their needs are more important than mine
and
so nice guys were again trying to avoid
that negative reaction the two things we
often most hide are our needs and wants
and our sexuality the sexual that's kind
of easy to to put a finger on you know
we live in a culture that we're
bombarded with sexual stimuli everywhere
you go but still there's still that you
know that religious message that sex is
Bad Evil save it for the one you love
shame yeah just the whole shame wrapped
around sexuality you'd think that would
have gone away by now but it's not it's
as strong as ever so for the the the the
the very young nice guy when kind kind
of back up a little bit back to to the
Child Development 101 stuff
again every child when they experience
discomfort of any kind you know they're
hungry and they don't get fed they're
they're they wet their diaper they mess
in their diaper they don't get changed
they're cold they don't get heal you
know they have a stomach ache they don't
get burped Whatever Whenever a child
experiences discomfort their children
are narcissistic by Nature emotionally
they assume this is me I I I'm the cause
of this I did something wrong I'm bad
they don't think it because the thinking
brain isn't on lineing at this early age
the emotional brain fight flight free
survival brain is and so a child will
try to do two things in a very primitive
way a non-thinking non-rational purely
emotional way they will try to medicate
the feeling States they're having suck
their thumb eat cry sleep smile whatever
to try to not feel bad right now and
again in a very pre very primitive
preverbal kind of way try to do try to
not do whatever that was that caused the
uncomfortable States or do something
different and so that begins at a really
early age and so the child is these
these this shame is is inaccurately
internalized at an emotional level I
must have done something wrong that's
why this is happening so I gotta figure
either how to do that different or not
do that hi and so all of this comes so
early is part of an emotional language
an emotional operating system it's not
in words it's not in picture memory and
it's it's primitive so here we are
trying to figure out how not to have
these uncomfortable experiences and
prevent them from happening again and
one of the best things our primitive
brain came up with is hide hide you know
what whatever that I have needs oh I
have needs I I get I'm hungry when I
have needs I get slapped oh their needs
are more important than mine so just
hiding is part of that because we think
it must be about me that's causing these
pain painful negative experiences to be
happening to us does this mean that nice
guys often have coping strategies maybe
they'll overeat maybe they'll be
compulsive with social media use or porn
or video games
or substances or
whatever the thing about that model I
just gave you that child development
model every human does that every human
we all just pick usually again based on
temperament and maybe just life
experiences in birth order we all pick
what are we going to do how are we going
to try to manage this and I sucked my
thumb times in kindergarten think maybe
I was trying to deal with some
uncomfortable self sothing self soothing
exactly trying to manage some anxiety
there so that's what I did now we we go
through childhood then we hit
adolescence and now we really want
people's approval and want to fit in and
be noticed and have attention all of
this really you know gets uh fueled with
with with uh our hormones and need for
attention where you know then it really
gets solidified and we pretty much carry
these routines into adulthood so yeah
trying to be perfect might be one you
know trying not to be perfect because my
brother was perfect and I couldn't you
know compete with them so I'll be the
opposite I I'll I'll make the mess um
yeah when I eat I sure do feel better
when I spend all my day and night
playing video games I I don't feel
stress when I'm oh isn't porn amazing I
didn't know that this existed look what
how I feel um oh you know if I get
straight A's look I I finally get some
validation but I don't know if it's ever
enough I better keep you know succeeding
performing you know I better get into
great amazing shape so I can be valuable
oh I'll never get in good shape so who
cares I'll just keep eating it can take
so many different forms and the only
real logic to it is the the infant logic
that you and I and everybody else had at
a few weeks and a few months old why are
nice guys bad
receivers because we think it makes us
bad you know the the thing is is that as
I said most of us is is most nice guys
internalize this belief well I because I
have needs that's why I I have these bad
things that happen to me if I don't have
needs bad things won't happen and often
again they I I could I could look around
in my family oh Dad's needs are more
important well let's all make sure dad's
okay oh now mom's unhappy let's all make
sure Mom's okay my little brother was a
general [__] up at pretty much
everything oh okay you know we got to
make sure little brother's okay because
he's gonna [__] up and I kind of like oh
if I don't have needs if I just kind of
do everything right I'll be The Golden
Child I'll get some validation you know
I I I won't get noticed too much and get
in trouble and and so again that my
story it's not every nice guy story but
there's some fundamental piece in there
that if if it's visible if people know I
have needs like that makes me vulnerable
it puts me at risk it gives people
control over me I'll owe people
something so in my own personal work one
of the earliest things I had to start
doing was was making me a priority where
I put well I did for me I I I'd do for
everybody else but I I wouldn't make me
a priority and you know I I'd make sure
you know my wife and kids they all went
to the dentist I wouldn't go to the
dentist oh they you know if I saw
something on sale I'd buy it for them
but I wouldn't buy it for me so I had to
start taking good care of me the next
step that that kind of came with that
but came a little bit later for me was
actually beginning to surround myself
with people who wanted to help me meet
my needs and then actually letting them
that was really anxiety producing to let
people do things for me and I I had to
consciously just go
okay I'm it's as simple as like I said
I'll take the garbage out and you know
we got to take the garbage from the
kitchen to the front gate it's 20 feet
gotta unlock the gate put it out on the
street my if I'm taking the garbage out
my wife will go do you need help well no
I don't I don't need any help to take a
bag of garbage from the kitchen to the
front and I and so I my gut respons
always say no but then I realize well I
don't need any help but she wants to be
with me she wants to accompany me she
doesn't want to think I'm doing all the
work well she's not she she's very hard
worker I go yeah yeah come help me do I
really need the help no but it was
actually it took me a while I'm still
learning that way you know she's not
really thinking I need help taking the
garbage out she just wants to come take
the garbage out with me just to walk to
the street with me and back you know
that's it's okay well who might have say
no to that that's the thing about being
a bad receiver it robs people of the
enjoyment of helping you you've you've
stole my words when um when I got I got
divorced in my late 40s after 25 years
of marriage to two different women and
again when I started dating and started
meeting nice girls you know who wanted
to do anything for me wouldn't ever say
what they wanted wouldn't make a
decision I thought oh I I had empathy
for my two Ex-Wives what I put them
through with being a nice guy but I
remember I was dating one woman and I
met her because she sold me shoes at
Nordstrom and she so she worked in
retail fashion sales and I remember one
time she came over to my part and I done
some laundry left it on my couch she
started folding my laundry and I said
you you don't have to do that she goes
no I like doing it and and she goes and
I'm good at it and you know so she folds
on my laundry puts a little stack on the
end of my bed and she goes but I won't
put it away for you I said I'm not
putting it away either I'm leaving it
out there to remind me somebody loves me
you know that that somebody wanted to do
something nice for me after that I
started leaving my clean laundry on the
couch so she could have the joy of
coming over and because it gave her
pleasure now who am I to rob her of that
pleasure and I need to work on it
because how am I going to receive great
things in this world if I'm not good at
receiving if I can't if I can't let
somebody fold my laundry how am I G to
receive the blessings of wealth of Fame
of opportunity of Adventure so it's is a
very conscious practice it was for me to
how do I let people give and let them
have the pleasure of doing
it so the solution is not being a bad
guy because a lot of people you could
try yeah so you
know nice guys finish last the bad guy
gets the girl um you know women will um
sleep with the alpha but marry the beta
you know Pick Your Meme or cliche of
choice they're all out there sure to to
to come up with and it seems let I'm
going to try and interpret what I think
the your philosophy is and and let me
know if I get it right
I
think the downsides of being a nice guy
although subtle and often completely
opaque to the nice guys themselves yes
are kind of evident given um can become
evident given enough crowdsourcing of
sense making so people and Community
come up with memes and and characters in
TV shows and stuff like that right the
solution that the low resolution
solution that then gets proposed is if x
x being nice guy is bad and doesn't get
what you want then opposite of X yeah Y
which is bad guy must be good so the
prevalence of Inc you know uh treat her
like you don't like her uh like why
women love Chads like that kind of more
um lothario approach to attracting women
and and and getting what you want in
life and sort of you know being ruthless
and stuff is that a an erroneous
solution to the problem of nice
guy it's the a core problem with what
you just proposed is it is equally
inauthentic as as the other and it's
equally attached to some external
outcome by trying to figure out how to
do it right right have I just do this
right again then I'll get the women to
approve of me we're still in the same
boat we're just looking for a different
right way of doing it now as simple as
this sounds you know like it when I do
like interviews with like uh a female
coach that that maybe works with men and
um and I say something that you know
generalization like the feminine meaning
all things feminine you know women but
dogs cats babies opportunity money
weather whatever I'll say is highly
attracted to a man who's comfortable in
his own skin knows where he's going and
looks like he's having a good time going
there and the women you know coaches
interviewers podcasters on the always go
oh yes and I'm going okay they're
they're reacting kind of their nervous
system is reacting to that thing I
didn't say the guy's an [__] I didn't
say he treats women bad I didn't say he
doesn't give a [__] about he he's he's
centered in his own body he's he's
differentiated he's asking asking
himself what do I want what's important
to me following through on that you know
not leaving the messes behind not trying
to be perfect not seeking anybody's
approval he's on Mission he's on purpose
and in my experience the feminine is
highly attracted to that you don't have
to work at at getting the feminine to be
attracted now are you always GNA have
feminine approval I told someone the
other day this has never come out of my
mouth before but I said actually there
is no standard of feminine approval the
the feminine is not about standards it's
just about whatever is moving masculine
is standards you you go into the
masculine world you know when you've
lived up to the standard when you've hit
the ball out of the park when you've
scored a touchdown when you made A's
when you you know made x amount of money
the masculine doing standards are clear
we can go into that world and go I've
achieved I've made it we have it we have
the status rigorous it's orderly it
requires something of you there's
discipline the Fe there is no such thing
as feminine approval I mean ask any guy
even a woman who approved of them dearly
in one moment I'll ask them have you
ever had experiences where the very next
moment she was unapproving of you and
nothing about you had changed you had
even done and guys all go yeah isn't
that the way it always works yeah they
you know one minute I when I was dating
I had women tell me Robert you're the
most amazing man I'm so glad I met you
I'm so grateful I'm so happy and then
never hear from him again or say Robert
you know after two weeks you know I'm
I'm taking a break from dating or I'm
giving my ex another try and I'm go what
just happen that's the world of the
feminine it does it isn't nailed down in
orderly so we we have to quit seeking
feminine approval um one of my certified
coaches wrote a book that that that I
really like but there's a line in there
it said that a man does not mature until
he quits seeking the love of a
woman as long as we're seeking love
that's a feminine trait as long as we're
seeking to get that approval that love
that validation from a woman we're in a
loop that there's no escape from but
when we when we can self- validate when
we're on purpose when we're living life
on our terms all of a sudden that makes
us very attractive to the feminine it
will come to us that's that's my
experience it will come now as soon as
you turn and go oh it's here how do I
keep it how do I make no no no we just
blew it all of a sudden now they're
gonna get that look on their face again
like I go what' I do wrong so if we take
the how do I get the women's approval
out of the equation you're more likely
to get it now does that mean you just
don't give a [__] don't care whatever
that's not what I'm again it's not black
and white we men want to make it black
and white it must be this or it must be
that no it's this this is another level
that we rise to that lets us put a dent
in the universe that lets us live with
purpose and passion that lets us connect
deeply with others that lets us be
vulnerable and courageous that actually
invites the the love into our life that
that we desire rather than seeking it
well ultimately I was watching this um
video from Alanda baton from the school
of life do you know that guy British
philosopher phenomenal Insight yeah you
you were the second person who mentioned
him in the last two or three days I
always pay attention when some whenever
I hear someone's name like you know when
I whenever I heard you need to get on
Chris Williamson show when I heard that
three times in the same week you know I
thought wait a minute that name sounds
familiar oh
we're already we're already booked in
I'm on he's on my calendar what do you
what do you know it's um so I I use a I
was just say what you're referring to he
wrote an oped article in the New York
Times maybe 10 years ago and and the art
the title was why you will marry the
wrong wrong person yeah I love I love
that article I copied it it's it's just
classic he's outstanding uh I've he's on
my Mount Rushmore of of of of guest he
was very formative for me um one of the
reasons that going to go on a tangent
about why I love alander Boton one of
the reasons I really love him is he's so
softly spoken and he's so embodied in
the Nuance of being fallible of how our
emotions run the show he's not posturing
he's unbelievably smart you know he's
very very well versed in Renaissance Art
and history and poetry and and sculpture
and and and and all all this stuff but
there's no posturing from his left brain
yeah there's none of this sort of over
rality he he accepts with complete Face
Value the fact that we can be
self-contradictory and embarrassing and
and all the rest of it but anyway he has
he has this line in a video that I was
watching
recently where he talks about a person
whose greatest achievement would be
after their death people would say they
never made a
fuss oh they didn't make a fuss they
didn't you know they didn't cause any
Ripple they didn't make any waves and
he's talking about largely uh an
equivalent of the nice guy this person
who's you know overly pliable who's
concerned about upsetting others who's
doing all of this stuff and uh I just it
really it really sort of struck home
like oh my God like that's
the that's the inheritance and the
Legacy which is waiting for you and
ultimately you can make it to the end of
your life having either made all of the
Messes in the world or made zero mess at
all depending on whether you go bad guy
mode or Nice Guy mode um but like your
legacy as you look back on your life is
going to be one of you playing a Persona
you're never going to really be able to
connect to any of the things that you do
people
accomplishments praise compliments
adoration money because it wasn't you
that earned that you didn't earn your
money
the role that you're playing earned the
money the role that you're playing got
the marriage the role that you're
playing got the relationship or the job
raise or or created the family or the
the billion dooll company it wasn't you
wasn't
you that kind of messes with your head
doesn't
it scary you know when you were
describing and I can't pronounce his
name pronounce his name aland de Boton
oh yeah that's beautiful when you were
describing him I'm sitting there
thinking I'm a straight guy and that guy
sounds sexy as hell the way you were
described I mean he's got the classic
philosophers build but so be it so be it
here here's something else so here's
something else that I've had in in my
mind um since looking at your work and
kind of I've spent a lot of time over
the last three years uh looking at
evolutionary psychology mating Dynamics
so on and so
forth we don't see especially from women
at the moment many conversations online
about nice guys about guys being too
nice about guys being too pliable a lot
of the conversation skews toward guys
being too toxic guys being too immature
but it's immature it it tends to be in a
in a toxic manner it's sort of the use
and discard the use and abuse uh the the
very sort of transient transactional
nature what is the reason do you think
that there isn't as much popularity if
if and I don't disagree I think that a
huge problem will be the pliability and
and dishonesty and niess of
men is it just less tweetable to to have
that is the reason that you can't find
men I've got all of these men that keep
bending over backward and keep doing
things for me is it that it's kind of
publicly unpopular for women to call
that out because it seems like they're
being ungrateful what do you what do you
think it is
well because I'm not in a woman's head I
I I I can't and and because I'm not on
social media I also but I I do know what
you're talking talking about of course
there are memes that that that that run
and I I do you know because I get a
Google uh notice every time nice guy you
know pops up somewhere I I do see when
it does pop up it usually pops up in
right-wing Republican writing um most
often but when women do write their blog
articles about nice guys it is most
often how nice guys aren't nice how they
used basically the cover contracts of oh
I'm going to listen to you talk about
your problems I'm going to pay your car
payment this month I'm G to pretend like
I care about you and then when they you
know asked the woman out or want her to
have sex it goes no I never thought of
you that way you're a friend you know
and and then the guy of course that all
that resentfulness that passive
aggressive the rage comes out and so you
know that Meme does show up but but it
still ends up being toxic
masculinity he here is my thought and it
sounds like you've looked a lot at this
and you might even have a better
perspective than
me my thought is that you know I grew up
during whatever the wave of the angry
feminism was in the 60s and 70s I don't
know if that's first wave second wave
but you know every man's a rapist and
erection is a sign of aggression and you
know that already bought in my mother
you know my mother's generation with the
first I think true feminist she raised
my my sister to not need a man raised
her boys to be different from their
father you know that was kind of the
beginning of of that movement and
um so from that I grew up I don't be
like those bad men the women are
complaining about so so kind of the
toxic masculinity me has been around for
a while it just didn't have social media
and now mainstream media mainstream I I
can't even listen to like NPR anymore
because it's kind of like it's just gone
so much to like let's just run fluff
articles you know fluff stories and
stuff like that agreed
um I think there had to be a pendulum
swing you know most of that's directed
at patriarchy you know now you just say
patriarchy and like we all understand
exactly what that means this evil right
but but patriarchy was also provide and
protect you know there was also
positives a part of it and was there an
ownership mentality yeah did that lead
to colonialism and you know abuses
towards women and children yeah uh
racism yeah so yeah all of that well you
know when we make a social change we
tend to throw the baby out with the bath
water so yeah let's just rail against
this big idea of patriarchy toxic
masculinity you know you know
mansplaining man spreading everything
that men do is bad kind of
stuff I I think maybe it had to go to an
extreme and and I think most social
sociologists that look at big shifts in
society say when you have an oppressed
people um down dra it almost has to
become like a revolution it has to be at
the extremes it doesn't needs to be a
correction yeah it's not like a Gandhi
that just you know let's let's subtly
create the shift um so I think there has
to be that overcorrection yeah and and
you know so we went through the hashtag
me too where you know men were you know
you know accused tried you know
prosecuted and you know in the media
lost jobs lost status purely because
some woman said oh I want to join the me
too crowd you know and yeah there was a
lot of abuses that were being addressed
should they been addressed through
social
media I don't know if that was you know
the most uh Democratic way to do it but
it's how it got done and then you know
yeah if you you know publish something
that gets a lot of likes and a lot of
follows and yeah other people are going
to publish it so yeah it went to the the
incentives aligned to make it happen of
course they do and social media is all
about algorithms and you know the more
something shows up the more you see of
it uh that's why I don't one of the
reasons I don't like social media um but
I actually think that we're actually
making an adjustment you know I I I saw
articles yeah a couple years ago
likening anything that had to do with
men's work to like the oh there goes the
balloons Jesus Christ
you said it wasn't gonna Happ I didn't
think it was going to work how have you
managed to make balloons come up on the
scen I promis I promise magic stop doing
it I I wish I yeah I can't quit moving
my hands now the thumb will probably go
up maybe maybe confetti all right all
right okay so even just a couple years
ago I saw articles about linking the
January 6th you know riots you know in
Washington DC to anything having to do
with men's work like complaining that
that all came out of the men's movement
and I'm going and this was in main this
Washington Post ran an article like that
right so it's mainstream
media I think actually that I think
maybe we've reached that that far
extreme and I think maybe it's starting
to where all of a sudden that's losing
its interest is it seems to you know oh
okay there's another meme about toxic
masculinity there's another meme about
Andrew Tate there's another you know
blah blah blah and people do boor and
now maybe in this because I'm in the
middle of men's work it's what I've done
for years and I'm I'm in you know a
men's program myself I built a men's
program I believe in it I I really do
think we're moving to a better space
that as men become more conscious um of
of the things that I think you know that
I teach that are valuable um you know
being honest being transparent making
their needs of priority surrounding
themselves with people on help get their
needs met living with purpose living
with passion you know being generous
making the world a better place being
openhearted being loving you know
quality good
qualities that I think is changing the
world is Shifting the dynamic women I
think will begin to go that that's
actually really attractive that's sexy
that's better I like that and um and I
think there'll still be a few ones
hanging on to but I let's all still stay
mad at men let's you know still and
after a while you know one of the things
that really was a big shock to me I was
probably in my 40s when I was I was
talking to you know a feminist and I
mentioned somebody who identified as a
feminist a woman maybe on an airplane
and and I said well here's the feminism
I grew up with And she said Oh you mean
that every man's a rapist you you you
like believed all that I go well it sure
was a he goes that was just a few angry
pissed off women that got a lot of
attention I go that's all it was not all
women felt that way she goes no and they
still don't I go that's actually good to
know then maybe all that noise that you
know gets a lot of likes and follows
maybe that doesn't represent the even
the majority of women there was a really
wonderful term that I heard last year
called the tyranny of the
minority and it happens yeah I think
that that explains it so another way of
putting it is the slowest dumb [__] on
the freeway is going to control how fast
everybody can go very good yes yes we're
controlled by the extremes and the
idiots
um it's interesting to think about why
that might be the case I I think that
you've probably you're probably not far
wrong
that it's still so popular
to fit men into the
oppressive tyrannical patriarchal
overbearing dominating controlling role
that if women were to if if a woman was
to Post online something which she's
more more honest perhaps which would be
um I keep going out for men who are
overly pliable and because they're so
pliable I'm concerned that they're not
being honest with me what does that
sound like well it sounds like a call
for men to be less pliable which is not
far away from men to be more aggressive
more controlling more writing a book
that's called No More Mr Nice Guy why
would someone write a book teaching men
to be not nice we do we do live in a
black and white world and again media
social media loves the black and white
it doesn't like Nuance subtlety that's
the dangerous the real n-word of 2024 is
Nuance that's the real one that you
shouldn't be saying all right so getting
into getting into relationships which
are obviously I think Ground Zero for a
lot of this stuff you know you can kind
of hide things away from yourself when
it's on your own and you're in and out
of work and all the rest of it not
everybody is emotionally connected with
the work and not everybody's emotionally
connected with how organized their
source cupb is relationships real Ground
Zero what do nice guys not understand
about how female attraction
works well most of us are believing what
our mothers told us you know uh if they
told us anything would just be nice to
girl that's what my mother said be a
gentleman okay makes sense you know be a
gentleman and I am uh I'm a gentleman
but a woman taught me this one uh I
always open the door for women I tell
them wait for me I'll open your door now
if you really break it down that's me
being dominant you know I tell them what
to do wait for me I'm gonna open your
door and of the of the several hundred
women who I've told to do wait for me
I'll open your door only one has pushed
back against it and she pushed back for
a while then all of a sudden she quit
and kind of decided she actually really
liked uh actually what she did as she
jumped my bones in a public place and a
very I said I don't we need to take this
somewhere else after the while she' been
pushing back against my dominance
so for there to be ATT traction there
has to be a polarity and polarity
involves dominance and submission I know
those are evil terrible words you know
uh because we think about dominant man
you know making women be submissive
you're you're in a safe space here I'm
not I'm not sweating it uh but yeah it
is all it is going out on the internet
which is fine you know and what's
happened is the polarity is just
switched where the females have become
dominant the dominant players and the
guys have become the the submissive
players and then the the women go how
come I can't find a guy that turns me on
and the guys you're going how come I
can't seem to turn women on well it's
it's is revers the polarity you you
can't have polarity that's attraction
without dominance and submission and the
more subtle it is the more subtle the
attraction is the more blatant it is
tends to be the more intense the
attraction is we've probably all
experienced that in one way or another
and I tell people you can't have sex
without dominance and submission
otherwise there two bodies lying next to
each other waiting for something to
happen you know you got yeah yeah yeah
fight you gotta have a top and bottom
you gotta have a pitcher and catcher
right there's got to be a polarity now
the beauty is that polarity can you can
flip it around you know back and forth
and I think in very conscious
relationships that that happens
beautifully my my wife's very strong she
grew up eight out of 10 kids in poverty
in guadalahara Mexico alcoholic father
got beat on by family members beat on by
neighbors you know abused by family
members abused by priests you know she
she's been through you know she goes to
the gym two hours a day she can out
squat me easily she's done my thigh I I
don't I don't piss her off um you know
she can get [__] done I grew up in a
middle class whitebred neighborhood of
Seattle Washington surrounded by Boeing
engineer families you know just you know
I I never had to fight for anything okay
so she's tough but she doesn't she's
always told me I love it when you tell
me no she goes I she goes I I don't want
to be in charge I don't want you to
always ask me what what you know what do
you want to do she she likes it when I
make we'll walk into a restaurant and
you know they'll here in Mexico and
they'll say they they'll say should I
they'll ask her should I get the waiter
say should I give him a menu in English
she goes no he lives in Mexico give them
one in Spanish and I'll say yeah give
give my wife and kids the menu in
English and then they hand her a menu
and she goes no he's my boss he'll order
for me and they always laugh about that
and I say yeah I get to be the boss when
she says I can you know we got the whole
the whole shtick down but the truth is
she is strong she's powerful she can get
[__] done she can kick ass but she
doesn't want to be in that mode all the
time she wants to to be led she wants to
submit she wants to open she wants to be
done to in in Blissful kinds of ways
well that's my job right so and even
though I'm kind of more that I'm I go
along to get along I you know I'm yeah
this or that either one's okay with me
I'm kind of more that way she doesn't
like it when I'm that way so for her
she's happy it's when I will play the
default lead the default decision maker
but she likes it best when I said here's
what I was thinking what do you think
you know I don't just say what do you
think you know what do you want I'll say
you know I was thinking a white with a
little bit of tent of gray in it what do
you think
you know she wants me to to to lead that
and then she'll feel the polarity and
then she'll tell me what she thinks or
wants and then you say you decide okay
let's go let's go let's go pick out the
paint um am I being abusive to her by
being dominant no I've heard so many
women tell me when the guy leaves it all
up to them too compliant the women feel
burdened by that most are in their
masculine dominant role all day long in
their work in their career raising
children even mothering is a masculine
dominant state to be in you're taking
care of kids needs that's not feminine
you don't them want to have to take care
of your partner after that yeah then
then when the guy says oh I don't guess
you want to have sex tonight would you
or what do you want for and it's is one
more thing that they got to check off
their to-do list yeah they don't want
that now am I making a generalization
yeah is it fluid yeah is it nuanced yeah
is it okay the guys's always got to be
the dominant woman's but no that's not
what I'm saying but for for men when I
start talking about them consciously
setting the tone in leading in
relationship when I say that to a nice
guy the response he usually he he'll
ponder it and go okay Dr Glover what I
hear you say when you say take control I
go no no you did not hear me S say the
word take control I did not say it I
don't believe in it I'm talking about
you lead you set the tone you state what
you want where you want to go what you
want eat and and and give her a chance
to follow like on the Dance Floor she
can't follow where you don't lead give
her that and then be open to a
discussion be open to her taking the you
know setting the tone and leading but
it's not about but guys nice guys will
say well you know when you said take
control no is more nuanced than that but
again so that that that's my job is
helping guys apply the the Nuance that
that word of
2024 what is the role of emotional
tension oh you've done some research um
yeah that's a cute little wink of the I
that just just flirting with you I'm
just
try I'm just trying to flirt with you
yeah I know the girls like it probably
the boys do too I I I live in a very gay
community so you know I know how it RS
um okay so the role of emotional tension
there we go we just had emotional
tension going on right there
yep I'm gonna I'm I'm going to make a
generalization that doesn't apply to
everybody but it does seem to apply to a
lot and this the generalized statement
is is that in general for women to
experience attraction say towards a man
arousal and to stay attached to that man
over time she has to experience some
kind of emotional tension she's got to
feel something the butterflies the this
the that the drama the does he love me
doesn't love me and we men can kind of
understand that a little bit we kind of
like the tension we feel of go oh she
she looks nice you know like her boobs
whatever you know that creates ATT
tension for us but in general men don't
like emotional tension especially in a
relationship if you even think about you
know our sporting events where we too
get our attention they have clocks on
them you know we know it's going to end
at this time that's why baseball's
fallen out of favor that's why they put
a clock on baseball they put the they
put the pitch clock last year yeah you
know problem how many times you can
throw it first you know because oh we
gotta have it on a clock you know so um
so men's tension is on the clock oh yeah
I I I I know this you know this this
adventure flick I'm watching in the hero
this is happening I know he's gonna get
out of it and it's gonna be done in 35
minutes you know it's done we're done
shoot go home kick back into nothingness
right the feminine never gets tired of
tension the feminine if it if it isn't
feeling tension is board it will create
tension and so that's what's hard for
men to understand you know we think
being nice to women will make them be
attracted to us but nice creates
absolutely no attention no tension
really for anybody men or women but we
think well that's what Mom told me to do
go be go go be nice to them it's what
that's what I in junior high all the
women were complaining about those jerks
who created attention for them and so I
listened to her complain about the jerk
and she kept going back to the jerk even
after you know you know I'm such a nice
guy so in general women need that
emotional tension watch it they create
it within themselves um and and we guys
if we have any kind of tension between
us we'll just have it out maybe we'll
punch each other and then we'll be done
we'll go have a beer it's all good you
know uh we don't need to keep going back
into that tension state to have a bond
to have a connection well we'll go do
something together we may go compete we
may go bring our aame and leave it all
on the field but then we walk off arm in
arm you know so so it's just the the the
the difference between that masculine
and feminine so the hardest part for men
to understand is that the women need
that attention so even when I say wait
for me I'll open your door and now I
create a little bit of dominance and she
waits for me that's tension all right
it's just a little bit it's a little
subtle you know even like you know say
hey put the menu down I'll order for us
tonight there's tension in that not
being nice it's actually creating some
what's he going to order for is he going
to pick something I like do I trust him
is it going to be an adventure you know
I I tell guys and you and you know guys
will think is game play and it kind of
can look like that and but the the the
real thing is actually just is how do we
get more conscious so I'll tell a guy
for example you know if a woman sends
you a message text message or calls you
and if you reply right away or you pick
up the phone and answer how much tension
will the woman experience through that
well well none we've relieved it soon as
we answered the phone her tension went
away but what if you didn't answer it
what if you called her back in 30
seconds 45 seconds an hour and she goes
where were you why didn't you answer and
what if you didn't give her an answer to
that and she's going why didn't he
answer what was he doing now here's the
thing because as guys tend if we do have
emotional tension we like what I call
positive emotional tension you know it
it it feels good to us where have for
the for women they don't care is it
positive emotional tension is it NE is
it pet or is it net negative emotional
tension they don't care emotional
tension is emotional tension and so you
know it means you know them starting a
fight you know them doing something know
they know's going to piss us off it's
kind of like they don't care they got
our attention and and that's all that
mattered they got our attention and
there's tension and even the thing of
guys like listening to women talk about
their problems I tell guys there's a an
inverse negative relationship between
the amount of time man spends listening
to a woman talk about her problems and
the likelihood he's going to get laid
what you mean it means that if you sit
and listen to talk about her problems
you've actually relieved all of her
tension tension flowed completely out of
because you know she talked she talked
she talk all all the tension came away
and what I tell guys is then you end up
looking like uh her girlfriend with a
penis and odds are she doesn't want to
have sex with her girlfriend so anything
we do to relieve their tension actually
works against us and robs them kind of
like we talked about earlier are we
going to rob them of the joy of doing
for us well are we going to rob them of
the emotional tension that they have to
have to feel to feel something to to
want to engage you had this fantastic
example of how emotional tension is
enjoyed differently by men and women by
the story arcs of romantic comedies and
how men and women uh experience
experience that can you explain that
well you mean like you know you you take
your woman to watch Titanic and she
Titanic you know she's already seen it
eight times and she walks away with her
panties wet thinking how come I can't
have that and the guy the guy's checking
his watch checking his phone is Sports
Center on yet how do I get out of here I
I thought what was particularly
interesting was you you explaining and
it really sort of hit home to me that uh
if you're a man who's watching a
romantic comedy you see um regul
at the beginning everything is is fine
then you see disregulation something
happens and everything goes up in the
air then you see regulation again on
like middle movie regulation where the
the couple first starts to get together
and you're like oh well I mean that's it
like let's go home the movies done yes
done whereas what the woman then wants
is this protracted oh but the
ex-girlfriend's back in the picture but
oh my God he hasn't got his right visa
and he's going to be deported how are
they going to keep the relationship
going and it's just protracted and raed
and protracted and protracted and then I
don't I don't know what it's like to be
a woman at the end of a romcom but it
may be unsatisfying for there to be a
conclusion it's like what could we just
let's roll it for another three hours
let's just continue to extend this T
that's maybe where where Bollywood
figured it out let's just do the wedding
scene everybody's dancing to a real
upbeat song we know it's over but now
they'll they'll do a part two of it
right
um and you
know women I've been in relationship
with learned don't take me to a romantic
comedy I'm sitting there going that is
so [__] unrealistic that doesn't
happen in the real world how come every
guy has a job he doesn't actually have
to go to how come every woman's a
fashion editor in every one of these
yeah I know he loves dogs but he lives
in this New York Loft and makes cans
that's how he supports himself come on
that's not real yes yeah you don't want
to go to romantic comedy with me because
I live in the world of could that really
be real could that really happen do
people really do that uh uh no you know
that's not how the real world works but
it creates emotional tension and so
that's really what it is all about it's
not about reality the masculine wants to
go resolve all the emotional tension to
get us back into reality so yeah I it's
it's really hard for me to watch a
romantic comment and just twiddle my
thumbs and just not not say anything oh
it's was excruciating so thinking about
this Dynamic that we have this emotional
tension this am amount of of of
dominance and and uh Direction uh and
and suggestion that comes from the man
um there will be women listening and out
there who enjoy they're writing a Blog
article about us right now it's fine
it's fine add it to the list but there
will be women listening who are maybe a
little conflicted or there will be men
who imagine that the woman might be
conflicted because you say well she
wants she comes home she's had a
difficult day at the work because Kelly
that [__] in the cubicle next door has
done that thing again that pisses her
off and the woman wants to be able to
vent she also wants her man to listen to
her and it's this odd duality of not
knowing what's best for us and of the
things that we want not always being in
our best interests right and you quoted
the best onion article which is woman
turns man into a partner she doesn't
want to be with i i i that that that the
article the headline alone is is enough
right you
know and and again this is this is the
dance of relationship wouldn't it be
great if you know we could just say guys
just do it this way every woman's gonna
like it no it doesn't work that way and
but what what you said was really true
is that yeah for example you know the
woman in your life's been in her
masculine all day doing at work putting
up with [__] managers [__]
customer
[__] clients [__] co-workers and
now you know she comes home there one
more [__] in the house putting
demands on her so for example um the
woman that folded my clothes that I
mentioned again I met her at the mall as
she sold me shoes and and after we
started dating um one of the things
where we really clicked is she liked
baseball I like
baseball Rangers Fan I could have been
part of a threesim it would have been
great there we go you go flirting again
but but but you you lost to me as soon
as you said Texas Rangers you
know those us were the World Series
championship in the last year yeah
you're you're the Wii you're the Homer
yeah we we won the World Series let me
see the ring man show show me the ring
okay so
um she liked baseball so you know she'd
get off work four or five o'clock in the
afternoon I'd already have a bar stool
staked out at the roof Chris that was
right next to you know where she worked
couple of baseball games are already on
the screen at the bar they have this
great half price hamburger during happy
hour she'd come in and she would just
start you know I'd already have the wine
ordered sitting there you know the you
know the appetizers that come and she's
like this about her day like that she's
been in her masking all day I would take
out my phone set it at five minutes and
say you have my undivided attention for
five minutes put the phone on the bar I
would give her eye contact I would face
her I would listen
undivided
attention she would run out of steam
before five minutes was up because she's
going I can sit here complain but
there's a baseball game on there's a
glass of wine sitting here what do I
prefer before I now if I didn't put her
on the clock at five minutes it was a
game it was me being dominant but in a
loving playful if I didn't put her on
the clock she might be crabby all night
long and she would not enjoy herself
because one of the things I found is
that for
somebody who identifies as feminine to
being their masculine all day are often
not good at getting themselves out of
that mask and all I gotta go home and
wash dishes and get the laundry dunked
there's things we got to do before I got
to get up and go to work tomorrow oh sit
down have a glass of wine tell me about
your let me rub your feet I'm a big fan
of of in a sense leading her back into
her feminine out of that masculine rigid
get [__] done kind of state of mind and
now all of a sudden she begins opening
and she'll tell me your attention I
might even say a woman taught me this
I'll say you know what I want to hear
about your day but give me the guy
version you know and I've never had a
woman ask me what does that mean I'll
say you you you want me to be your guy
right yeah yeah all right then I need
the guy version when you tell me about
the
day about how Kelly in the cubicle next
to her you know well and I know why she
does it because she just insecure and
she's always wanting attention and she
always takes it out of me dear I love
you give me the guy ver
Kelly pissed me off today great now I
understand why you had a bad
day so you know get playful with it get
playful with it there's definitely one
of the common threads that I'm noticing
through a lot of the Dynamics is a
degree of playfulness and it's my nature
so it is what I bring and you know it
it's helping it's helping to it's
helping to relieve the tension relieve
the tension it's helping to relieve the
seriousness of
everything that it it gives more play it
gives like in the engineering term it
gives more room within the system for
things to breathe you make a suggestion
but it's not it's not done in too rigid
of a fashion there's there's there's
movement in there and it's done it's
evident the reason that you're doing it
and it's not in a mocking way it's not
in a passive aggressive way it's not in
a condescending or patronizing way but
the reason that this I think works is it
shows Hey look like we're here to enjoy
our time together we're you're here to
enjoy we're here to enjoy this and
whether it's someone's had something
good happen someone's had something bad
happened someone's sad someone's mad
someone's
whatever the appropriate amount of
playfulness I can struggle to think of
really many situations in which it
doesn't make it
better yeah I I and that doesn't mean
getting silly and everything's a joke
because again guys will kind of like Oh
you mean make a joke about it and go and
again teaching men to to be
light-hearted that that that that can be
a pretty daunting task yeah um now
what's funny though if you get men with
men and and let them just kind of begin
to let their hair down guys get silly
with each other and you know and but
we're I think we're afraid of showing
that to women oh yeah I won't I won't
appear manly I won't be you know there's
a degree of there's a degree of
competence I think uh I certainly notic
this do you know who Charlie hoopet is
from Charisma on command he's got a very
big Charisma Channel on YouTube a really
really great guy very embodied ton of
self-work ton of men's work um and he uh
helps mostly men but also women become
more charismatic so he he he's he's
learned the principles of of confidence
and Charisma and um one of the best
tools that he teaches is when people ask
a question the best answer isn't always
the right
one and you know he uses this example of
um how to overcome your discomfort
around trying to be funny and he says if
you walk out of the house and you're
with people you walk out of a bar or
whatever and the weather is one extreme
of either hot or cold make a joke about
it being the opposite yeah and he was
like it's the shittest joke it is the
worst it's a pure dad joke but he said
it'll get a chuckle out of people if you
walk outside and it's freezing hot and
you go dude wish I'd brought some shorts
today this is great um like people have
a little bit of a a chuckle about but it
really really showed me and I have a
friend George who's been on the show a
lot he a lot of the time if you're
playing kind of like a game of tennis so
you're playing a game of tennis which
involves a linear conversation here is a
question there is an answer here is a
question there is an answer here's
another answer here's another question
and you play this back and forth he
regularly hits the ball sideways so
he'll call back to a thing that happened
a couple of weeks ago or he'll say oh
you know I bet that such and such a
famous person from the media would have
done that or whatever like he'll rip the
conversation out like orthogonally from
where it is and there's play in that
he's not answering the question because
he he has the comfort in himself to not
need to get validation by being I am the
person that always knows the answer I am
the person that is always able to give
the the correct conclusion that draws
the line that puts the full stop and
dots the eyes and crosses the teas I
don't need to be that person and it's
such a breath of fresh air because
you're having this conversation and and
you're like I'm excited that I don't
know what's gonna and it f it engenders
that in you as well but there's
definitely like good boy energy and nice
guy energy in I will answer the question
properly I will ensure that this you
somebody has asked something of me and
deliver it I shall and that removes the
playfulness yeah you know and and when I
work with guys around this when again
when I when I learned to date in my 40s
and 50s I you know I was never good with
women and if I got one I kept them way
too long and I started getting
successful you know with with dating and
getting laid and guys said Robert teach
us I'm I'm not a dating Guru but that
what you're talking about is that again
for most of the men I worked with they
get so afraid I'm gonna do something
wrong I'm gonna make a mistake I'm gonna
piss her off I I'll blow it and then
then it's irreparable and I'd say you
know just tell her don't you know if you
have the impulse to touch her touch her
if you have the impulse to tease her
tease her if you have the impulse to
tell her come on let's go do this don't
hold back it's crazy as it sounds I tell
guys blurt and act on impulse you think
that's a recipe for disaster but the
truth is it lets them be themselves
because their authentic self comes out
and you know I've had so many
experiences you know around what if I
just blurted acted on impulse you know I
remember one woman I dated on the second
date we're going to go go for a walk and
she said well let me go use the restroom
in a a restaurant and she went to the
restroom came back and I so I'm going to
go use the restroom I said by the way
enjoyed watching you walk away from me
and as soon as I said it I thought oh
[__] I probably blew it you know after
we broke up we saved friends and she
said months later said you remember when
you said that to me said yeah I thought
I blew it he goes oh no I I loved it
well I it I just blurted it right I
didn't hold it back I remember another
woman ear early first date were walk
and she said something about her her
sister sister-in-law they're they're
having a shoe party you know women get
together and look at shoes buy sounds
like the lamest thing a tupperware I can
think of a shoe party lamest party in
history but okay and so I blurted with
that thinking oh shoe shopping is
women's porn she turned and looked at me
she goes you get it you understand you
know and and and so guys will say well
I'm not funny you know I'm not I'm not
you know I can't I'm not talking about
telling jokes I'm talking about whatever
that thing that came to the tip of your
brain but you held it back yeah because
you're afraid it might be the wrong
thing to say the wrong thing to do as
soon as you held it back you killed the
tension the putting it out there and
sometimes you crash and burn you know
there's the sweat flops you got oh man
that didn't get one laugh you know but
you got to take that risk every comedian
you know has had plenty of bombs to but
man that one landed and and it's not
about trying to get it right it's about
taking the sensors off and letting that
you that maybe just speaks to the
obvious out there and people people
they'll relate to it or they won't it
seems a lot like one of the key tactics
for rehabilitating a nice guy is
learning to kind of get out of your own
way that's a good way to put it because
what we've been doing is again go all
the way back to where we began this
they've been trying to manage their
shame I'm I'm bad I'm not good enough
I'm GNA be found out I'm GNA die their
anxiety oh no somebody will react
negatively there would be pain involved
a and so that is what's driving the bus
is their shame and their anxiety and so
who is really in there you know who is
the person um one of the things the
comments I get from people that that
work with me or you know come to my
workshops or seminars or or do calls
with me they'll say Robert I appreciate
how how authentic you are and I'll go
nobody would have accused me of that 30
years ago nobody would have said Robert
I love how real you are how authentic
you are how you just share yourself how
how you share your mistakes your fuckups
I didn't and and I couldn't attract a
woman to save my life you know back back
in those days I I I kind of could but I
I didn't know that what I was what I did
that my attract a woman but I wasn't
real I wasn't authentic I was holding my
finger up checking the wind I was a
chameleon you know what's what's going
to get me the most laughs or what's
going to get me you know what What will
what will kind of go over well but not
too well that you know now I'm not on
the spot that I got to follow through
and man to just take the sensors off and
just blurt act on impulse be you I think
is such a powerful Rehabilitation and
since most nice guys their sensors are
the prominent with women that's a great
place to go
practice one of my the same friend I was
talking about before Mr orthogonal
tennis game George he uh he has this
idea called only the irrational Behavior
survives what he's talking about what
he's talking about is he imagines um
being at the funeral of somebody that he
knows and he thinks about the
conversations that the people are having
around the room and they're not having
the conversation the washing was always
folded and he turned up on time and all
the rest of it he uses this example of
his mom and he says that his mom hates
fighting just really does does not like
physical fighting big big problem with
it and once his brother was in the car
his younger brother was in the car with
her they were driving somewhere and she
I don't know 50s year old woman normal
British woman uh saw two 18yearold boys
sort of squaring up to each other and
pushing and and trying to fight or
whatever on the side of the on the
pavement she stops the car in the middle
of traffic
gets out and runs over and the brother's
like Mom what the [__] are you doing
like what the two guys twice your size
and quadruple your testosterone what the
[__] are you do she runs over and she
gets in between them physically gets in
between them like no fighting no
fighting gets back in the car and the
brother's like Mom that was insane you
could have been hurt you could have been
she's like I don't care I don't care I
just don't like fighting no one's
fighting and he said at her funeral
people will say she was the sort of
person that would stop the car in the
middle of traffic to stop two boys from
fighting
and it's like that only the irrational
Behavior survives is is similar to what
you're talking about that there are
rough edges to our personality and our
Behavior but ultimately that is our
personality and behavior like if your
goal your goal should not be as a person
on this planet to smooth out any of the
things that make you anything into this
sort of vanilla amorphous blob that kind
of like just Glides through it's like no
you have things that you want to say and
actions that you want to take and
changes that you want to make and just
the faith to be able to do that
unencumbered is that's what life is yeah
and and and it it takes support it takes
practice um yeah you talking No More Mr
Nice Guy about nice guys being Teflon
men no stick you know nothing I don't
want anything to stick to me but we do
connect as you said around our rough
edges you know what we remember about
people might not even be always a thing
it it might even bugged us or got on our
nerves when they did it when we're
around them but it is also the thing we
miss I mean you know Nala the pitbull's
back at my my door again I've got french
glass doors so I can see her outside my
office yeah you know when she barks
during you know I'm on an interview a
podcast it really bugs me but you know
if I didn't have her and I'd notice oh I
miss her bark you know I love when go
crazy and let me know that somebody was
out front our our handyman the the water
guys deliver our they call my dog's name
because they know she'll bark
differently when she's had her name
called and then well and I would miss
that if it if it ever went I'd go what's
wrong with Nala how come she doesn't
bark at people outside
anymore yeah it's it's rough edges B you
know all that smooth get it right no
yeah that's
boring why is your first sexual
experience so important
you talking about
mine the
FLIR come on even that's too far for me
um yeah first sexual experience why is
it very formative okay you
know that that that's a good question
but it's also a difficult one to answer
because our our first sexual experience
is probably conception you know I'd say
birth we're born sexual we're the the
essence of Who We Are is sexuality every
living thing is built to reproduce after
its own so our sexuality is the essence
of who we are we kind of live culturally
thinking well you know children don't
become sexual until you know that
particular age whatever that might be
but the truth is you know little boys
little girls discover their body parts
that are very young age and oh there's
pleasure before you you know they
understand the words of parents tell
them stop doing that you know they're
they're they're they're they're finding
the pleasure in their own body parts and
the essence of our psyche is is is are
are is sexuality you know if so many
great teachers you know all the way from
from Freud to David data to Osho to
David snar people at least I value talk
about the the most profound way into who
we are young is to our sexuality because
it is the essence of who we are so to
bring that back to answering your
question I will often ask people like in
a workshop you know again I primarily
work with men these days well I 100%
work with men these days I'll ask them
what was your earliest sexual memory and
it doesn't matter what it was first time
you notice you had an erection first
kiss first wet dream first I'll show you
mine you show me yours first whatever uh
and it can vary you every but I say what
is your first memory and then I'll say
get it get clear in your mind what was
it and then I'll ask them did it occur
in the open could you go tell your folks
about it could it be celebrated did your
parents say that's amazing Lo get let's
go get pizza that's a you know it's a
developmental
milestone um or was it hidden was it
secretive was it guilt-ridden was it
shame based uh even worse did it feel
good but you felt bad about it feeling
good right so for about
99.9% of the people on the planet our
earliest sexual experience was wrapped
in shame in in Hidden Darkness guilt I'm
bad I can't let anybody find out so our
sexuality gets cross-wired with those
features it's bad it's evil hide it
repress it don't let it out and then
that takes you know as many different
forms as there are people in terms of
how that manifests from from there so
then we get to be adolescents and adults
and can't figure out why sex is so messy
so difficult so challenging so you know
how come it isn't work how come how come
it's not easy yeah people who think that
they have a a low sex drive might
actually just be psychologically scarred
from the way that they perceived it
that's very possible I and I've often
said you know I
I we'll get I didn't discover I didn't
know I could actually masturbate myself
to ejaculation until I was a freshman in
college that's pretty late compared to
to most and and you know I was kind of a
late bloomer in a lot of ways around
sexuality and I was just well that's
just me but yeah it's very likely Me
growing up in a fundamental Christian
Church where I heard messages really
early that if you lust after a woman's
breast you go to all you go to hell for
all eternity you know where you know my
mom taught me to be not be like my dad
where you know I listen to the women
that he's a jerk he only wants one thing
you know yeah there might have been some
scarring that went into you know I'm
trying to work out you know it's better
to not have a sex drive oh my penis
betrayed me again by getting a wrecked
you know what stop doing that you know
you know I'm trying to work out from a
first sexual experience perspective my
first the first time I had sex the girl
who I worked with at the local hotel
where I was the room service boy
do you know what a uh [__] what was
it
a a VW Lup is L Lup it's like the SI
it's smaller than a fat 500 and it was
three door and it was in
a uh like an industrial estate halfway
between did you have sex in the Lup I
had I I if you think that having sex for
the first time is difficult having sex
for the first time in a car that's like
half the size of a jumper just turns the
turns the difficulty level up to 11 um
but yeah I maybe maybe that's I don't
know what that means we were next to a
like a
mercedesbenz mechanics maybe that's why
I love F1 so much I'm not sure I keep
getting an erection whenever I see Louis
Hamilton I'm not sure uh we we could
really SP my my my first attempt was in
a a Chevy Vega you know probably
slightly bigger slightly bigger the next
time I tried it it was on a parked
school bus I got smart right yeah very
nice very good well I mean the school
bus but um yeah it's it's it's very
interesting to think about how we sort
of internalized these stories and hey I
had uh do you know who Dr Paul Conti is
is that was Stanford I've heard that
name I couldn't tell you who he is but I
have heard the name so he did a
four-part series with Andrew huberman
last year I've heard that name too yes
yes everybody says that name all the
time he's fantastic they're both
fantastic and um Paul does uh
evidence-based unconscious work trauma
uh and such from a very medical
standpoint and um he was talking to me
he gave me this really lovely frame very
interesting about how formative
experiences in our past can reshape the
way that we see the entirety of that
world but importantly they reshape our
memory of what it was like before that
as well so for us to say something like
like uh I get in a car accident when I'm
25 and uh then you get travel anxiety
which causes you to not enjoy driving or
to feel anxious when you're driving and
then at 35 you tell yourself I've never
liked driving you're like no until the
age of 25 you loved it do you not
remember you did that thing it's like no
no no no I was anxious the whole time
and this this ability that like the
fallibility and the malleability of our
own memory and our sense of self and our
understanding of ourselves um the fact
that for sufficiently formative
experience expences can like manipulate
those and mold them in a different way I
just thought was so it's fascinating but
kind of brutal as well well and maybe
this is the same another way of
explaining the same thing every time we
recall a memory we fundamentally change
the memory because every time we recall
it we're now in a different emotional
state a different position different
surroundings we accurate memory does not
exist right what what even even as we
think we're remembering our earliest
sexual experience you know if there was
actually a camera there filming it we
might find out it was completely totally
different surrounding wise than we
thought so every time we recall a memory
we're altering it so our memories keep
changing over a lifetime so um but what
but what happens that that trauma we're
talking about and that what I call the
cross wirring that's happening at an
emotional level and so it doesn't matter
even if our memory is accurate in terms
of you know digitally accurate what what
matters is
emotionally how we move forward with it
and so now if you know we've been a
sexual creature since birth and all of a
sudden something happens that sex is
hidden well I better keep it hidden from
from here on out and we don't make that
as a conscious decision it's just an
emotional road map that we start
following it's very very interesting
okay so we identified this yeah and
people are sitting listening to you and
I talking very openly about sexual
experiences and they're going you're not
supposed to do that you're not supposed
to talk openly about those things
because they're going on their emotional
wiring of how you're supposed to to you
know be about sex yeah well look the VW
Lop opens all sorts of doors um three of
them exactly precisely correct unless
you can clamber out the back honestly
dude I I and I remember how not far the
passenger seat went back as well I just
thought this is [__] and you got to
do it in the passenger seat because with
the steering wheel but you guys have the
steering wheel on the wrong side of the
car well speak for yourself look we've
gone through this Litany of problems
right this big big big big list and we
don't have enough time to prescribe the
Panacea for all of the nice guys
listening given the fact that you've
done so
many seminars coaching sessions working
with people what have you found if you
were to give the biggest movers of um
Rehabilitation for nice guys um I don't
think I've ever used that exact word for
it what what what are the uh the
practices what are the places that they
should focus on in order to start to
embody themselves more honestly okay
yeah be be their authentic selves
exactly I I'll just walk you through
what I did number one I tell people find
safe people don't try to do this on your
own you didn't become a nice guy in
Social isol isolation don't try to get
over it in Social isolation we have to
say have safe people to start releasing
our shame to tell people I've got this
story about myself and people go that's
not bad that's not terrible at all
you're that's normal what you're
describing so we need safe people to
support us release our shame perhaps
Mentor us encourage us help us face our
fears so I tell nice guys go find a
coach therapist men's group I love men's
groups did a big chunk of my own
personal re rehabilitation in in men's
groups uh I was leading five men's
groups a week when I was in private
practice up in Seattle um I just I'm a
Believer so fine men's group don't try
to do this alone how do you so just to
interject that how do you know if it's a
good men's group or a bad men's group
that that's a good question and it is
somewhat subjective because something a
group you love might not work for me
um when I started looking for something
about that existed at that time was the
uh the Robert blly mythal poetic go out
in the woods be the drum have the
Talking Stick and say ho I did that I
ended up in a 12-step program is where I
started not wasn't by choice it just
where I landed um I I got lucky I I
landed in I was in a men's group led by
a woman around sexual shame who liked
men and so that was good for me I tried
some other men's groups that I I just
never connected or resonated with
with a core piece I would recommend
whether you're looking for a coach a
therapist a men's group is find somebody
who leads it who's actually done their
own work you mentioned embodiment quite
a bit somebody who's actually gone out
worked on their own stuff you know I I
became uh a therapist I I got my PhD in
marriage and family therapy at 29 years
old started you know a few years later
started doing you know trying to do real
therapy I never been to therapy and you
know it wasn't until I got into therapy
in men's groups and started working on
my own toxic shame and my own anxieties
and my own patterns that I could
actually really help people so you know
um it doesn't hurt to check out you know
ask the person what's your journey you
know where where have you worked on
yourself and then just see do you
connect with them that's that's usually
a good place do you connect so go go
find a coach therapist men's group 12
group something where you get to go
start revealing you releasing toxic
shame start being honest nice guys think
they're honest were anything but honest
I remember pretty early in my process I
I realized almost everything I told my
then wife was whatever won't rock the
boat so I I told her I'm gonna work in
being honest whenever I catch myself
making up a story to tell you I'm going
to come tell you I was going to lie to
you here's the lie I was going to tell
you here's the whole truth truth so I
started doing that and actually I used
to tell her her middle name ought to be
overreact because that's what she did
and every the funny thing was when I
actually just started telling her the
truth about [__] she'd go okay thanks
for telling me that I'm glad you didn't
lie to me and you know whoa that's
different you know when I was trying to
get her not to overreact she did when I
just told her the truth yeah okay don't
lie to me that was it so work on being
honest and again we need safe people
usually to do that uh work on making
your needs a priority start asking
yourself what do I want what's important
to me you know am I do I do I need to go
to the gym do I need to go the dentist
uh do I need to take some time to relax
uh do I need to rest my eyes do I need
to go read a good book do I you know how
do I get my needs met and how do I let
people help me get my needs met and how
do I surround myself with people who
want to help me get my needs
met uh start working on boundaries
that's that's a big one for nice guys is
well nobody grows into adulthood knowing
how to set boundaries because nobody
teaches children how to set boundaries
um because in in the real world the big
people get to do whatever they want to
the little people and because we were
all little people we never learned you
could say no stop that I'm gon to remove
myself now so learn about boundaries I
was in my 30s in my second marriage with
a PhD before IID ever even heard of
boundaries a therapist I went to taught
me about them uh so start working on
boundaries and then I just I think the
one other piece I'll throw out there
that I think just so fundamental
especially for guys for nice guys go
connect with men go build a tribe of men
I've had to do that a few times in my
life about seven years ago when I got
married down here in Mexico um not yet
fluent Spanish my wife only speaks
Spanish and I'm living at here working
at home I I had no guys in my life and I
went seeking and found a men's program
and joined it and
now if you looked at my text messaging
my calendar my email I'm on Zoom I'm
messaging with buddies all the fraking
time and it just it makes everything
about my world better I'm I'm more on
point with with my work my relationship
improved I'm in Better Health I'm
happier so build a connection with man
so there there's about five things that
are a pretty good start
Dr Robert Glover ladies and gentlemen
Robert I adore your work I think it's
very much needed it's so fascinating
that it's been around for quite a while
you know and and yet this single thread
of guys being overly pliable of
resenting despite the fact that they're
playing the game correctly they think
that they're doing all the rest of it is
uh it's so fascinating and I I've
today's been phenomenal where should
people go they want to keep up to date
with your work you've got TR the
internet
yeah drg glover.com you know good place
to start out uh it's we're in the
process of rebuilding it but you you can
go find good stuff uh integration
nation.net my new men's program uh my
co-author said be sure and mention the
big
stick this uh go find the big stick Tony
endelman is a certified coach I I I
asked him a few years ago Tony what do
you think about digging into everything
I've ever created and trying to put it
in one book and he goes yeah I'm up for
that I go okay and he did did a
beautiful job so um drg glover.com
integration nation.net big stick hell
yeah Robert I appreciate you thank you
very much for Chris this was a blast
thank you so much fun if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe